foreign
[Music]
correction Texas tag Romeo Sierra Yankee
zero two nine seven rsy 0297 it's a
black Mercedes
signal 12.
[Music]
23.
45 please
[Music]
yes
Alpha 2 24 plugger
uh
vehicle's still rolling
can you go give us 10 33 till further
yeah
stop the vehicle pull over do it now
foreign
what are you doing
we've had our lights and sirens on since
I-95 and you've taken this long to pull
over
[Applause]
any reason
huh
all right
[Applause]
okay you're driving all over the road
too
you're not maintaining your lane
you almost blew through that red light
are you having any kind of a medical
emergency
what's that
okay you may favor shut the vehicle off
shut your vehicle off for me
shut your vehicle off
turn the car off
it is a very simple thing I'm asking you
to do
let me see your keys
let me hand me your keys hand me your
keys no
okay step out of the vehicle for me
step out of the vehicle
step out of the vehicle for me
come on out bud
ah you okay
I'm still doctor for the office because
I haven't you're good come on
all right
no what's going on
um
what's up
what what's going on
well I asked you if you were all right
you said no
correct so what's going on why aren't
you okay
why aren't you okay what's going on
so what's go what's what's going on with
you Mike if you're you're driving all
over the road okay
you ran off the road a couple times all
right you about well no it's not fine
that's why you're being stopped and then
we had our lights and sirens on behind
you you weren't stopping for us
so like what's what's going on I I don't
know what
would sit for you to say
things are not oh
we got an ambulance coming to check on
me man
not yet
okay well
all right
okay oh yeah
under the influence
I know
it's Sunday